to get the final shot
[Music]
that's usually this man doing it to the
basket for hardin for two
does it every time james harden
whether it's a three or a two
if they so chewed
harden
pulls the trigger
got it
james harden is houston's throat
[Music]
oh my goodness again each one is better
than the one previously
he drives kicks the harden martin with
derozan there
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he has scored the last seven make it the
last nine for the rockets
just fake van lay out of his jock strap
yeah that's right she made that shot and
made it look easy
boy is she a good swimmer
and he'll go to the free-throw line to
add one to it harden curry switches off
four to shoot
harden shaken bait steps back
three-pointer bang
[Music]
how about that a 45-foot pass from james
harden to clint capela
so will mike d'antoni
needs those points between the legs
[Applause]
action right off the bat
shot clock at seven seconds
cazonia and hardin
hart steps back fires
[Applause]
[Music]
james harden
is the new scoring one game champion for
the houston rockets and calvin murphy on
his feet
shot clock at six now for the rockets
hard and fakes gets past crowder gets
inside throws it over his shoulder and
puts it in count it and the foul as
harden with a chance for the traditional
three-point play
the nets have taken more threes than the
rockets here tonight
[Music]
martin
euro
the finish james harden getting to the
cup
[Applause]
rockets have numbers at least for now
behind the back and then the hero
stepped up for clint capela the best
sequence of the night for houston
and
[Applause]
jimmy butler is still down holding his
right knee as hard he gets it to go do
you think he was certain
to work i thought it was going to be
oh man hard oh he stared at wesley
johnson and then he hit the three
wow
he put him on the deck and then he
hesitated
final seconds of the half
here is hart
throws it up and goes and it does
james harden beats the buzzer
barton garnered by the rookie little
shake and bake pass inside the nene
gathers lays it up and in
beautiful assist from james harden his
third here in the first quarter let a
team like this
get into a game early
oh what a great move
by the beard
can't guard him 101 of course
18 seconds left to play rockets need a
three the tie
james steps back
[Applause]
james harden gets his first
three-pointer tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
oh that was a big hammer a little back
down dribble get a separation because
anderson has some length
he's got the last six for minnesota as
harden takes it strong to the goal
gibson
is on heart
looking around him and he hammers it
home
[Applause]
undrafted in 2015 played overseas for a
couple of years it's been an impressive
rookie this year as hard and hits the
bottom
[Applause]
[Music]
once again
no problem
just like that
he baits him by making it through
all right thank you david there's
hardens with the drive
dust
a facial by james harden going right at
draymond green and a lot of chatter out
there miller
gave it all there's kristin ledlow work
on the sideline
i would expect that he would sit here in
the fourth quarter down to four seconds
down to three
behind the back razzle dazzle there it
is
james harden with his ninth free of the
game
let's think about it the guy was at home
without a job
hard blows past james and throws it down
fatigued
[Applause]
[Music]
82 combined between harden and gordon
got fouled
and one
that's a half a hundy for headband
summit on that play both guys were
determined
to get a play for their team harvey
[Applause]
robinson was a great shot blocker
patrick ewing
jameson blocked this
step back
oh
a cold-blooded three for james harden
and that may be the game-winner
[Applause]
[Music]
arden backs up and tries it again yes
he does it again
james harden trying to inbound
harden trying to get three
down to three down to two it's a three
good
he got it
james hardened a flame thrower
just murray and harden
five's licking his chops
he fell down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
got another one
shaking his head
looking at milwaukee's bench saying you
can't guard me now
step back
oh
it's a three plus one
they go once again going ahead of pacer
and stolen by harden
for the slam to seal the deal
[Applause]
and that's capello
from the parking lot
[Applause]
he was out there in the parking lot all
by himself
he's smarting over there on the opposite
side of the floor
good defense by kyrie
wow
butter by james harden
damien lee comes in for the first time
curry and green return
hardin step back gets down and one
chance for a four-point play as hard
knocks down his first three-pointer of
the game in our league yeah because he's
a good penetrator good hustler yes he is
number one draft choice that's going to
be two-and-one jackson saw him coming
couldn't do anything about it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my
somebody give kent base more a map so he
can locate james harden
seven seconds
on the shot clock
[Music]
over are you kidding me
he shot that from sugarland
to get past that
rebound goes to capella
back to hardin
oh i think he was up so high
he got a bloody nose
i love that celebration i love that one
this kid can play he's getting an
opportunity
between the legs to capela
showtime
[Applause]
hardin
throws it up and he goes in everything
this season is going in for james harden
they won 65 games last season so this
season was just about the postseason and
then they had
hardened
at the buzzer shot clock again down to
five
hard step back three
harden tonight three and seven
thompson's defense there
step back
three down
he's done it again
rockets will have the lead at the break
the question
will be by how much
moves
[Applause]
and the crowd has a little bit of light
back
fires
looks was all over him and it's still
within
that's targeted to the front row the two
ladies
pass
james hart capela eight straight for
houston fouls to give both in the
penalty
under two to play hard to step back puts
up the three got hit shots good and one
james harden double team had a chance
for a four point play
he just
looked at the crowd and said wow
like he is in awe of himself at this
point don't reach because he's gonna
preach and then you're forced to close
out
hard drives
oh
baby blockers don't call a play they
know what they want
hopefully it's a mate three
[Music]
[Applause]
and it is
to beat the buzzer in the third quarter
picked up by pj tucker off the harden
and there's smith right there
jr's on him harden goes by him and
connor to go pretty play by james harden
houston got its hands on it
dort for three blocked by hardin dork
got it back tried to throw it off harden
and missed him
[Music]
covington defending harvey
covington trying not to give up the
three hard and step back three
[Applause]
two in a row for james harden in this
seventh and final game here's durant
for
heart one on the shot clock hardened
fighters away
switch
harden oh
the handles and the bucket that was
sweet
[Applause]
talking about talent
and explosiveness
he is fun to watch
and should be in cleveland for the
all-star game
meanwhile another turnover hardened
behind the back to griffin wow that time
for the four months in the off season
that can make big strides on his body
and his performance
backdoor simmons powers it down
smith guard getting his hand on that
and just that quickly gave it up simmons
behind the back he's got company
navitsky back and slamming in the face
of the future hall of famer is ben
simmons both guys taking fade away
jumpers joel on one end matthews down
the other end
embiid launching another three
brendan simmons somehow put it back
here the sixers out of the timeout
slamming it down
putting the exclamation point on this
one
three inches shorter and about 10 pounds
lighter
ah simmons stolen and slammed it for two
ben simmons
did it again
rising high for that one that's a story
we've heard so many times with so many
different nba players who were growing
up in new orleans displaced by katrina
simmons rolling in and hammering it down
oh my
not a lot of fun yeah not a lot of fun
at all
especially if you're not in the
offensive
oh ben simmons throwing it down yet
another dunk for him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh at the back door ah simmons threw it
in reverse
wow
marvelous play by ben simmons simmons
out there with robert covington j.j
redick this guy daario charge who goes
back door to simmons one more to embiid
that my friends is basketball
eight points
six boards and six assists
simmons tomahawks that one he's looking
for the call as well on heartless
doesn't get it
that's all the steel moments go by ben
simmons his fifth of the night to tie a
rookie career high that is reddick
simmons wow throw it in reverse
turning garbage into sparkling gold
61 is the evolution of the nba game you
got to be able to oh
rondo oh
no he didn't
ben simmons is out here just putting on
a clinic with the basketball
the sixers aggressive defensively and
quite frankly the cavaliers out of sync
simmons nicely done for covington it'll
be a time out to ron lou
[Music]
difference in the game the cavaliers
three-point shooting
they have 11 more trips to the line as
ben simmons throws down two
12th lead change of the night we've had
14 ties as well
simmons all the way to the cup and he
threw it down
jared jack
hawked the whole way up the floor by
mcconnell
and now mcconnell on the steal what a
defensive sequence from mcconnell who
finds simmons for the flush
[Applause]
impede on the bench out of the timeout
ben simmons time for him to get nasty
shot
would you be okay with robert shooting
that from that position one of the
reasons why he's there simmons great
hustle kept it alive cruising in and
slamming for two
a marvelous play by ben simmons and
laurie markin it was the seventh pick in
the nba draft again it's simmons and he
got the dunk
he has desired this entire first quarter
[Applause]
not as popular to play that way
[Applause]
as we see the nice move and finish by
ben simmons
you love playing with guys like that
because those are the guys that keep you
out on the floor when you're playing
pickup ps a gorgeous
look by ben simmons
especially the grammys as covington
picked it clean
can he get it to simmons what a play by
covington
and simmons slams for two
[Applause]
felicio lost it
should stop dribbling the ball
simmons
delivering 2mb
games the heart of a lion mr walker
[Music]
simmons throwing it down big time a
terrific move by ben simmons to get all
the way to the cup to make it an
eight-point game cleveland two on the
road and what i like is i figured out
what he's doing to deploy he's lighting
a match when he rubs his hand on the
floor that was some fire right there
pretty play for charge
vince simmons right now with eyes and
back of his head he's got six assists
already
[Music]
simmons great look and that'll be the
triple-double for ben
nice defense on him by walker
sixers trying to squeeze off walker they
do simmons is gonna solo and he throws
it in reverse
and against simmons tracking a
triple-double boy the sixers really
engaged eventually that time michael kid
gilchrist was enveloped there's simmons
throwing it in reverse
compliments a tj mcconnell ben simmons
like a lot of sixers fans market i'm
sure you i could include you in this i'm
pleasantly surprised to see him getting
stronger
talk to me
talk to me about the young fella would
you please son ilyasova on the floor for
the first time and he promptly leaves
kevin love feeling rejected no love for
love hug nope not oh again
[Applause]
[Applause]
10 with all that flash behind the back
[Applause]
tatum made eight three-pointers in the
seven-game series against milwaukee 14
points here in game one reddick gives it
back and simmons with the left-handed
throw down
you're completely off him and got to the
hole the turnover with this group good
hands and very active defensive group
for philly
warfare turns it over now sevens all the
way in
two-handed jam by ben simmons take the
chance
to slip two spots
between the legs
not just between his own leg sevens but
between horford's legs as well what a
pass
and here's simmons coming up with a
turnover a great idea look at that look
at that oh what a play by simmons
i didn't think i'd get that excited in a
pre-season game
morris and simmons
simmons just takes it off
what a play by simmons
finishing the game that's what you want
to be doing down the stretch when the
game's on the line you're in the lineup
all right nicely done amir johnson
dropping a dime on ben simmons really
struggled in the first half it's young
for three
and simmons has it for the sixers nice
spot of covington who throws it down the
fifth assist of the game for simmons
where you don't use the backboard for
any kind of support wait davis gave it
away simmons at the center of it all and
he'll slam for two again
[Music]
when he can score negan scoring bunches
we talked about again that cavalier game
last year when he was in new cleveland
wow
[Applause]
ben simmons finished the job complements
our furcon cork mod toronto shooting
just five of 16 from the field
simmons oh beautiful look from simmons
down to butler
randy hollis jefferson who appeared to
be shaken up earlier is back the sixers
come up with a turnover
wow
[Applause]
well those tough passes yeah i'm sure
you've run the floor and had some really
weird passes coming
look at that
no pass there simply a slam for simmons
alfonzo mckinney this time
green lurking to help behind the back
butler
hits and he's fouled
green steps under him trying to land
that's a heck of a pass by simmons hard
move by plumley he would not be at the
top of the list of offensive options but
that was well done simmons they left him
alone and he punches it home
because he gets a lot of looks like that
well the things we talked about what to
watch they're there for a reason nice
catch wow i'll tell you what simmons
thought he was fouled but quite the pass
as well from mv i like that number 25.
he's got some good mojo in it al
jefferson is the last hornet to wear
that number
terry rozier ahead of the pack is
blocked away by simmons
two for one opportunity for the matching
if they work it right scott getting a
piece of the rock it triggers the sixers
milton for simmons who threw it down
what a catch with one hand by simmons
jones and dragons blocking him out
richardson never hit the ball
his defense has been pretty stellar this
year hasn't it oh he's a terrific
defender oh wow
bringing that smoke on the putback
simmons has aaron holiday now on a
switch trying to clear out and take him
give him some space here he goes and he
slams for two ben simmons first bucket
of the third quarter meaning injury he
is starting
when you're gonna play young you gotta
match his energy he's gonna crash every
time oh beautiful slam by simmons off
the feed by milton
neto playing some serious minutes in
this one again shake milton on the bench
with four personals ben simmons cork
screwing in able to get a tough two even
before that injury mark talk in san
antonio was he's the point guard of the
future tony parker gone nice pass ben a
brilliant look by simmons his third
assist the first quarter goes back to
when i was in high school
wow i know think about that yeah that's
a long long time ago
ps matisse bible hits the three
well he had dwight howard swiping at air
on that dribble penetration uh-oh
simmons wild attempt
he put the english on it off the window
[Applause]
joelle into action and bead for the lead
simmons the tip did it come before the
expiration of time
did the officials allow it presumably
they did because the final scoreboard
shows 113 to 111 but the replay will
bear it out only a second bucket at
seven tries and of course they love that
here in wells fargo center well the chin
up was i thought necessary
ben simmons answering back
shares it with west brook finally a
little bit strong tobias harris has it
simmons always looking for early offense
not a bad leave on the take what a
finish wow
incredible let's see if he can stay with
him can you keep him under control from
getting into the paint two on one at the
other end collins couldn't get the alley
and knocked away